So this is 2 point hospital this is the game that is *clap clap clap clap clap* about
*clap clap clap clap clap*
HOSPITALS (echo)
So we're gonna get into this and we're gonna make a hospital and we're not gonna die a horrible terrible death
This is where people go *clap clap clap clap* to get healthy and once they get healthy they
*clap clap clap clap clap*   Follow me on instagram @he_has_a_spoon
pay me money. That's how it works. When people go *clap clap clap clap* get healthy, they pay me
*clap clap clap clap*
money. i get
maahhny (money)
Money and health.
Make-a sense-a?
Okay, here we go. I can't hear a damn thing. Whoa, that's, huh, does it hurt? I can't... what the fuck I can't hear anything. What?
So..What is that?
I can't hear anything. Yeah, whatever
I can't hear anything is there supposed to be any sound in this? This is just a bunch of crap
This a bunch of crap. This is what you would call crap.
I'm Albert Crank,(?)
I got no voice. Get the frick outta here. Alright, whatever. Okay, I'm sure the opening was great. I don't give a fuck
what my friends are doing. You think I give a shit about my friends? Go away friends. Alright, whatever.
(nobody does)
Hog sport. You can hear it now? Oh good for you. So can I. You're not special.
You're not special at all. I can hear it too. And that's all that matters.
Are you ready to start building your first, fuck off fuck off. I know how to fuck off ;)
Fuck you! You piece of shit. Fuck you, Albert Crank!
oodladdll moving the camera
loodaloodaldoo
I know. I'm aware. I'm aware.
*"yaabuulbul" gibberish*
Items. OK, reception, whatever, fuck off.
I want people to go in the back.
All right, here we go. Easy peasy, okay people are gonna have to go all the way...
Here's reception. All right, so people got to make the long journey
All right want a system where we go Blake punya. No Sally mal for
Wendy Bajor, you got it. All right, Wendy
All right, listen, Wendy you piece of shit. Where are you? Where are you? I'm here
no, Wendy look at me! Wendy Wendy look at me! Wendy, look at me DaMn It!!
Wendy Wendy damn it. Look at me. You look at me when I'm talking to you
There you go. Wendy you look at me
Oh, there you are Wendy.
Alright, room building? I don't care. What are you talking about? All right, Wendy
Now you stand over here in the corner in the naughty corner and you listen when I tell you *interrupts self* this is so loud
Why is this music so loud?
stop
Stop. I; stop, I'm trying to mouse that; SToP doing
here robas gp
Okay, she's never leaving so we don't need her door I
Would like him to be able to walk right from the office into here and then walk out window, never mind
Okay, I may ignore that why wouldn't I want a window
Here
Why wouldn't I want a window there? What do you mean it doesn't look into the hospital? It's in the fucking hospital
What are you gonna?
Whaddya, whaddya you talking about?
Where else would you want a window?
What people get naked in this? Why would you why would you do that? That doesn't make any sense? This is so stupid
What? All right fine, I guess here's the peeping window where everybody can see in that makes sense office desk
Yeah, okay Thailand Cabo, okay
bin
Extingo, kay plant
Okay, where's the?
"Music and news" NO "of to point County" RICKY "you're listening to us from the newly opened hospital"
"Just turn up that volume because nothing drowns out the sound of sick people like the voice of a world-class
DJ" Who the fuck are you?! "42 hours of music from the background
Enjoy!" Okay, shut up and go away and Wendy, what are you doing?!
Wendy what are you? What are you doing Wendy? Wendy, what the fUcK is wrong with you?
Wait, and now everything's in the goddamn middle of the office. No, that's stupid
Wendy god damn it. What happened to your desk? Did you eat it? He's stupid. Okay, whatever. I guess we don't need it
All right. Dr. Chuck Boff. You got it
All right, Chuck *siiigh!*
What are we doing? It's open for business. We don't even have a reception desk. Goddamn. You ruined my day
Oh you piece of shit. Oh, you stupid desk. Can I move this room? Edit
move
There and now you've got a window. All right, so you got that
Fuck off with that
Yes, we're done
There we go
Stupid piece of crap. Okay, I'm gonna make a reception
Right there Wendy get back to your desk right now
We got a customer on the way. Customer. Oh, yeah. So what do we do? What do we do in this game?
What are we supposed to do? Are we supposed to make people better now? I'm sick my bladder
Exploded I can't believe it. I'll go to this room now
Let's be Chuck coming here to
Examine your bits. I'm gonna pop into my office here
All right
Pop on with this. Oh, wait, no. Oh I thought
That's not the way I put up the desk, all right, whatever don't matter Wow
Is that it only the pharmacy oh
Shit get patient. Ooh, wait you wait right there lady you wait right there
A Pharmacy, huh
Let's see
Big. This is where *mumbles* this is gonna build like a CVS in this thing. All right, so that's the pharmacy
There's the door. Drug mixer? *giggles* well
well
Yeah, give me the drug mixer, all right. Filing cabinet. Very important. Bin
Equally as important
Extingo, also important. Plant? Very important.
And thats that then. Okay we've got our pharmacy. That seems about right.
Is that gonna happen the whole goddamn game to five if I have to endure that bullshit I am going to stab somebody
Okay. We need to hire a nurse Marcus spatula. You got it
BLAP all right nurses in the pharmacy. Are we actually doing anything here? Are we actually making anything happen in that pharmacy?
That might be a little small maybe a little bigger
Was cliff wait hey
Good idea for it. You have like false false paths
Stuff like that people think they're gonna be going to the pharmacy in reality. They just go to a dead end
That's what I wanted my pharmacy
Yeah, yeah, you think you're gonna get out alive. Nah, no way. I know how my pharmacy is just cavernous
Just absolutely
Cavernous, there we go
Where's the where's the entrance? I don't know, who knows who knows where it might be. I don't know. I think that's good enough
All right pharmacy. Pretty good. They're gonna die. They're not gonna die. It's not like they came in here on an ambulance
They're gonna be fine. Probably. Anyway, they're probably gonna be totally fine. And why aren't you moving faster?
We obviously need more drug mixers. Where are the drug mixers?
leaflet stand
Snack machine okay drink machine. This is where you make the big bucks
This is really where you make the big bucks. Oh, yeah. Nice sitter's. Oh
yeah, I
Don't feel like that should be something too proud of and you should be a lot less peppy than you're steppin. It'll attract more
Yeah, you got cured good job janitors. Oh hell. Yeah
TeX BuThUrT...
Get in here Tex
Jane grot yep. All right. Here we go
Rose digestive sure thing nurse. We're gonna get elect Alexa Mubble
Items for the how do you get specific rooms for the items? Ah,
Items, here we go more
Scuse me?
Oh
I did it nevermind. Okay. Well, I got that underway
It's important to keep your staff and patients happy to ensure a hospital run smoothly. It needs more plants
I don't think I can actually put any more plants in this I have no idea what I'm doing
plants..
Can make it like a haze and Lyga hedge maze kind of thing going on here
Conditions at the Rotting Hill Hospital are getting worse every day
Apparently patients are just as likely to die from sinkholes and crumbling ceilings as any diseases
At least that'll keep the huge day
Okay, all right, thank you build a staff room I'd have space for a staff room
How am I gonna build a staff room then size three by two?
Oh my god. Oh
Good god. Oh my god. I don't know. What's she doing?
Hey, do you have something in your hands? Are you all right, can I help you?
What is your deal?
What are you doing, thumbing up everything?
What's wrong with you? Okay, so I need to get rid of these things
Or I'm gonna make a room. I'm like a staff room BLAP easy peasy. I know where to make a break room and
BLAP and if you guys could wait a second before you're being assholes about it, couch already got that
Refrigerator. Oh no is this up? This is some kind of a locker situation. There we go. Block the windows with the lockers
Yeah, we didn't need anything else. Anyway, I understand plant
plant
That's entertaining for a break room
Fire Extonger, no can't do dart board. Okay, good enough. I did it
Okay toilet Oh God, okay. There's one in theres door
Here's one pooper, I can't even fit one pooper in there. What are we talking about? Can't fit one pooper
Are you kidding me? What is garbage? Okay fine, then this goes here fill one pooper in here
What are you kidding me? I can't fit one pooper. Whatever. Okay, I need to get rid of this thing
This go away this go away. God damn it. Not even room for one pooper
Just let me build a pooper this year one pooper, please
one pooper one Cinco
Are you okay? It's got a toilet it's that's all it needs. You don't need to wash your hands
Why would you need to wash your hands you don't?
done
It's got a poopy right there
First again no my mistake. Anyway. Keep those fingers green
Okay, whatever okay, man, I don't even understand you okay the pooper is open where poop town USA
What are you guys confused or something? What the hell are you confused about?
I don't understand what you're confused about new illnesses general de god. I'm just trying to build my hospital
Why do you keep adding new elements to this shit? I just want to build a nice hospital. I don't have a good time
I want to get duh
Whatever cure two patients I did that I did that
General Diagnostics. All right minimum room 3 by 3. Which space do I need?
That's gonna do it and I'll do it that there get slapped on the old table there
Let's get two tables. So, you know couples couples Diagnostics. I can't put two tables. Fuck you then
Why did I need a three by three?
There's a lot of empty space. What a fuck do I need to put in there? I guess I'll put a reception desk in here
Put a pooper in here. Where's my pooper?
Okay
I put it over in the now what if they got what if they got horrible pooping disease and they gotta explode the poop out
Of their poop hole. I don't even understand put a plant in there. You're right
And by you're right, I mean shut up. There we go. Okay, all good in this neighborhood fast speed
Can I go faster and whatever that's fast speed really that's fast speed. Whatever
Ward unlocked. What does that mean?
What do yah mean a ward?!
What?! Build GP offices hire two doctors? Well, I can hire two doctors easy. Why do I need to build another office?
Why can't they share an office?
Tex Buthurt is unable to get to where they want to be. You might need to range things to unblock his route
I don't think I need to do that. I
Don't think I need to do that at all. I think you need to shut up. That's what you need to do
You need to get a whole lot of shut up in your life. All right, fine, whatever this that helped
All right. I had to shrink my pharmacy a little bit which I hate doing it, but I had to do it
Apparently I thought I hired another doctor didn't I hire another doctor? I thought I hired another doctor Amy tundra place
There you go rooms
GP
There you go doc and
Cabinet and we're good got it nailed it can it's a little wrong, but that's okay. Okay doing good
How big is the pharmacy not big enough, but I don't have enough space for it
So God do what you got to do, you know, we've cured ten patients in total Wow
Whoa, golly. Gee
Any more janitor to save the plants are they dying? No, I guess I do need more janitors
You're right. When you write you write when you write you write and you write you write you write
What is the Q about well, I was trying a bit. I was I was trying to make more won't let me make another I
Can't make another I want to make another one but it won't let me make another one even I know the queues long
I'm trying to
Well, let me know. I'll just hire more nurses. I guess. Maybe that'll help
Does that help I can't make any more. I want to make more. Why does it not? Why can't I I
Want to make more why can't I not you need a ward? Oh, I don't want a ward
I'll be this award Oh Deluxe clinic. Oh, whatever God why do I need to build so much crap?
Four by three. I have a room for that. Oh god, damn it. I gotta get rid of my maze
I'm not gonna get rid of my maze. I don't care who you are
I'm not getting rid of my maze not getting rid of my maze
There we go. Okay. Now the ward is gonna be back here
Done there we go. I don't know what this is all about, but they're that
Privacy pooper I guess
Super pooper. Is this a pooper might be a pooper? OOP Abed poop
bat poop
Poop bed. Whoa bad done
Ward's done remove this
There and then I have enough
It said my level increased but it sounded like a bad thing, why did it sound like a bad thing?
I got to build a deluxe clinic here for some reason don't know why but here we go. Deluxe clinic BLAP
Here we go. Get a door and get out. Whatever. This is. Oh
Well, that's a thing, all right, whatever got that I don't know what that's all about but
That looks violent and I kind of like it because of that. How do you need should I put like two beds in here?
Go on the pooping room. Oh, oh. Oh no. Oh god. No. Oh god. No, okay
All right guys fine. I probably should have put two pooping beds in here really wasn't smart about my leg. Yeah
I want two poopers. There we go, and we're done right? What the hell?
There we're done. Okay. Now we got to pooping beds
We need another doctor. Okay, we need a doctor Anna BeEvEs
There you go Beeveeses. All right Beeveeses is there. You didn't add plants. you right
When you write you write and you is right. Was that one gonna die? Well shit, huh sucks for you.
Did you just go in the corner to die and you're back up Oh
They just kill them they just kill that man
You're gonna die now I know you're gonna die I'm very aware that you are about to die. Yep treatment failed and you're dead
Well, I wonder why they freaking ripped your head off is this okay, is this fine is this fine?
Is this is this just fine? Are we just gonna are we just letting this slide on this one do I?
🙌🙌 meme review (hehe)
Okay, all right well then that's nice boy, are you sniffing that plant smooth snog your nuts no
Wow
You are sad
Okay, cure three patients of lightheadedness. It'll happen. Maybe the light bulb is lightheaded No
Is it is it really Wow?
Are you sure about that?
You think wait?
Hang on maybe you're not (INTENSE CAMERA ZOOM)saying that if they got light bulb on head that light headedness
No, that went over my head (HAHAHAHAH)
because I know get that thank you for point out to me
That is very good of you
Thank you HaRD 😩😩
For your help to me that I understand mine and brain no get my brain never get it would never get you know
You know me and brain bad me and brain you wouldn't bring good. That's how you brain
And I thank dear hospital administrator one-star hospital. Congratulations. Your hospital had been awarded a one-star rating
That's out of a possible three by the two-point Health Ministry
I have retrieved your file from my bin to celebrate continue to develop your enterprise for further esteem and train kits I got
Kadosh, I unlocked lower bollocks. I
Didn't know they could go any lower than what they were
Fragrantly your fragrantly yours. That's funny. That's funny. All right. Let's get out of here this place
And if you happen to be in lower bullocks this morning watch out for the gathering of druids down the Broadband's rang
in a total coincidence
The town will also pay host to a psychology convention today should all work out nicely
What the hell?
What the fuck were you talking about? Why were you so depressed the hell was that? Alright? Let's go to lower ballsack
psychiatry room
That seems nice
Okay, why would I want to go through the trouble of building this all again?
I had a perfect place and now you're saying that I got to do it all over again for some reason
well
Lutie duty, fuck you you be I don't understand what I need to do here
Can we just be purely psychiatry or do we have to have like a variety of stuff? Why can't I just do one thing?
Why can't I specialize in just one thing? Why do I have to be a hospital that does everything?
That's a whole lot dumb. I don't want to do that right here. I go. Anyway, alright Pharmacy time. Oh,
God, I'm gonna make it a nightmare if it totals up to the area that 3x3 would be then it should be fine, right?
What a load of bollocks am I right
Okay got that. I know it needs a nurse. Shut up this guy no, too expensive this guy
Alright, he's there we need general diagnosis. That's fine him three by three my god. What is the point?
you're right there and
There, okay
Good
Karam ward or whatever that means let me block this doorway
Apparently not
Shit well fine. Then that's gotta be an exit there that uh, ah,
Blammo abalam Oh a blammo abalam Oh nurse station
Right there and a screen
right
Perfect
Right by the window so everybody can get a good view about a ward. Okay. What do you have? Oh
God
Mocks star that's stupid
Shut up. All right psychiatry
Face away from me if you can. I don't want to look at you while you're sping stupid
All right higher we need a doctor. Okay, dr. Duckworth
Hey, you seem all right no you you seem fine
Okay, what else we need we need a staff room all right staff room we'll be right there
Okay, that's the staff room
couch
Done. All they need is a couch apparently staff room easy. He's a PC. Okay toilet drug mixer too
Drug Mix too you say? I don't mind me a drug mixer too - all right
Where is the bathroom right here?
turlet
Sink, you don't need a sink. I
Suspected that you did not and you do not
Know washing our hands here. Click the drug mixer then the star. Well, that doesn't seem right
Yeah, whatever
Shut up screw you do I need a janitor or something? Simon mackerel not too expensive
All right, we got that. Okay, we're good, right?
Go fast mode
Great. I'm a very I'm a very good hospital ER
I'm like, I'm like the best hospitalized ER in the world plant is what I need. You're right when you're right. You're right
and you was right plant plant when plant
plant
Oh, come on man
Dude, what the hell?
Stupid a-hole. Okay. Are we good? What else do we possibly need in pans lab? What the what is the pans lab? Oh
God damn it. Okay a pans lab
Sure
Whatever. They're all my plans. What is that? What is this? Okay, I
Don't know what that is, but I love it. It's gonna be horrible. Whatever. It is plant land plant or what else we
Deluxe clinic. There we go. Good enough
and
Pretty good, what a nice Hospital I've got here man
That's real nice. Why do I need nurses?
20 nurses bad nurses too. Sweet. Okay, whatever. Oh, well, I need another one. Why do I need another one?
All right Lester. Okay. There we go. I think we're good Louie NYE and another doctor or something probably another doctor too expensive
Okay, goody goody. Goody. Good. I think we're good to go, right
Okay, whatever they're doing they're doing whatever they're doing own two buildings. Wait, what does that mean own two buildings?
Why would I need another building? Why would I want another building? I don't want to own another building. That seems oh, I don't
Tear down this lovely playground or this patch of dirt
Do I take over the patch of dirt this patch of dirt or the playground?
Well, goodbye kiss
Sira
But Dad I like swinging on the swings, can we go on the seesaw?
Oh No
Sorry son: Brock
No playgrounds for any children cuz this guy's gonna have the common courtesy to die outside of my hospital
No, he's gonna go somewhere in the hospital. Yep, right there by the toilets. Yeah, no one goes ever anywhere near those
So why not? Maybe this guy needs to hurry the hell up?
Hey review
There you go. Nice raze for you, buddy
You better work faster, though
Because I hate you better than the first what are you talking about better than the first the pharmacy isn't even girthy enough
The pharmacy is not nearly girthy enough. I don't even know what the hell is going on with this pharmacy
It's pathetic who says I have too many nurses and also, how dare they smooth
Us numb
there's Norv I
See you over there. Go back for seconds one more. Oh, maybe I shouldn't though you've
No, but I've got a patient now. Okay, I have no idea how this is gonna work
but uh
Okay Wow
That's pretty stupid highest priced janitor this guy's gonna be a nightmare
Nightmare of clean lack of girth is a major problem for pharmacies. I'm aware of this. I know this why don't you uh,
Why don't you step into my office?
Really frightening dimly-lit bleh
Wait, no, not this this isn't what I wanted. Damn it. God damn it. I wanted a
GP's office fuck that's what I had. Here we go is what I wanted. Why don't you
Excuse me, I need to go get your file
That's nice, I need to hire a new doctor apparently. All right. So who's the cheapest? All right Bella goop
You go Bella goop
Oh
Next this is shout at the top of the lungs
I'm practically dying. Well need help real bad
Really weeds out the fakers, you know, if they can't make the walk to the chair then they actually do need some help
Can I tear is there in another playground I can tear down? That's what I'm really looking forward to no plants. You're right
There we go
All done, why do we need another doctor? What do we need other doctor? What happened to the doctor?
I had thought I had a doctor whatever. Hey I
think my hospitals failing pandemic patients
There is a plant there's a plant this is a lovely plant here Janek
It was play where we need this please go 90 days without a death. Uh
Yeah, that's
That's gonna be a hard one. I don't know if we can do that staff request
Request denied. You know what?
Red team meeting everyone gather like look listen
I know you guys don't want death for at least three months, but we just can't have it. It's not in the budget
We can't make it work. Hey, sometimes we all gotta pull up
What is this shit all right, okay, here we go open
The burp award Wow, oh my god
I'm ready. I'm ready. Oh
Oh
Oh, that's not us. I got an expensive janitor now. Come on. I've got a great janitor. I've got an incredible janitor
This is bullshit. Oh
Come on
This is a load of crap
better
I'm a great employer. There we go. That's what I thought lower ball sack. Hell. Yeah
Hell yeah, I know desk no desk baby. Oh that one guy. Just had to die outside the bathroom god, damn it
Okay bungle Meditec got no desk. Yeah, I doubt that. All right, most prestigious
Okay, never mind then. How about Patients Choice Award? You know my patients. They love me
Such a good hospital, right?
We're loved by the people
Yeah
I'll take it. Don't take it. I'll take it. Yeah Oh
They'd like some place to sit would they well, they can't have it we just don't have the room I spilled some
Put some more plants celebrate squeeze one in here. Yeah, we can, you know, we can play this nice plants
Hospital the place is goddamn. Nice. There we go. There we go. That's looking good poster
Okay, making so much money
🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌🙌
All right, cool, okay. Goodbye warm greeting to you all this fine morning
Especially those of you in fluttering we're renovations have been completed on the bridge that leads to the town's ancient castle
Officials say people crossing over will no longer need to wear parachutes and lifejackets
Just won't be the same. I hate you radio, man. What's all this tutorial bullshit? How do I get to the real stuff?
All right, I'm gonna build build this one so good. I'm gonna build a hospital better than you guys have ever seen
I'm gonna build the bestest
Bestest hospital in the history of hospitals. Ooh, mine is gonna be I'm gonna tear down apartment buildings make the best
Goddamn Hospital
You have ever seen just wait just you fucking wait, I'm gonna catch him right at the entrance
I want that booed ambush him with like yeah. Hello. Oh, yeah, just like smash him in there. Okay
All right, and then as soon as they go here, you know what they're gonna be hit with two
luscious
General Practitioners as his offices. They're almost stanky with how lush they are. Nice conveniently placed filing cabinet
I like it a nice bin for puking in when you get bad news about your death. I love it this one
How do I copy can I copy? Here we go
Easy peasy, but I'm gonna move this over here and conveniently place and by the door, all right
Just that easy I'm gonna make the best fucking...
Ever it's gonna be the best
everyone's gonna be like, oh
It's gonna be good. Okay, just you watch this. Just you watch everybody. Shut up
I want thigh Oh everyone's like oh
I'm Mark I can't do nothing as I know you won't you have no idea you have no idea
This isn't even my final form as they say on the Internet's. Let's go
That's what they say oh
Yeah now that is what I call nice
All right, okay everybody shut up
Everybody shut up. Yeah, you know, you know I had to do it to him. You know, I had to do it to him
You know that I had to do that to them. Hang on. Oh, it's we're just getting stanky in here
We are only now just entering stank zone turlet turlet
Sink the ship make the best fucking Hospital
Everyone was all like no, there's no way you can't do it marks just an idiot shows who the idiot is and it's you
Make the best fucking Hospital you've ever seen
I'll get ready for this shit
It has only just begun you thought that you thought that the slaughtering of how awesome my hospital is was done
It is not even close to remarkably done. I've got this on lockdown
General diagnosis. Oh, you know, you know, we got some general diagnosis reserved rooms, you know, what else they need
plants
Whoa. Whoa getting good in here. Hang on everybody. Shut up. Okay. All right. Okay, okay
Yeah, okay
Okay
donezo got it. Nailed it. Okay done
Okay, everybody. Hold on. It's gonna be the best fucking Hospital you've ever seen in your life Deluxe
Staff room deluxe. Well, I'm talking legit. I'm
Talking too legit to quit the most legit break room you've ever seen in your life
Lockers out of the wazoo. There we go. Okay, we got drinks machine
We got not drinks machine. We've got a bin. We got a plant we got poster now
That is that's legit. I'm even gonna unlock a television
Yeah. Oh
Yeah, and a private television for this guy, oh yeah, no, it's good. That was good, okay
What else do we need now? I need the specialty stuff. We need psychiatry, which is its own beast entirely
Super calm and peaceful area like real legit
Calmness going on here. There's a lot of relaxation happening
There's a lot of chilling out. You don't need nothing in here
There's a trash can for when you got to throw up and you got to feel safe with all the light head posters
Really?
Fucking really just around you just just surrounding you that's all it is. That's all we really needed. That's good
Okay. All right, everybody shut up. So
We only need one more left
Which is the pans lab?
like Pan's Labyrinth
Hang on we're not done yet. You may think that we're done. We're not done. Oh, we are not done and with that
my friends
That's what I call a good Hospital
Put fire extinguishers around here way. Let's just make sure make sure we're safe and
Open for bidness. We need to hire people into closed for bidness get some cheap-ass janitors in here
BAM plenty of Doc's you
nurses
BAM
Dunzo ones. Oh, here we go. I
Got this on lock baby. Oh now that is what I call a good Hospital about it guys, right?
Give it up for me cuz of how great I am of how good this hospital is everybody gets a clap train going
everyone just keep it going never stop because you know that I'm the best and
Everybody can only understand that I am the goodest. So, thank you
For blessing your eyeballs with the beauty of this hospital clown clinic
The hell what?
Wait, what wait a minute. Hang on. Why do I need a clown clinic? Where do you train them?
wait
Wait, where do you train them? I don't have enough room. I
Can't oh god damn it I made oh
All right
There goes the symmetry everybody. All right. There we go. Done got it nailed it. Okay
Now we got training room baby. Okay. All right. Let's put somebody in start training course for clown
nass
Motivation that's what they need to start training trainers guest trainer. There we go. Now you need motivation you all need motivation
All right, here we go. We need a psychiatrist. I'm always getting quite low. Not sure we can afford to bills
Do you think we need a loan? Can I get a loan?
Bad face no know what that means. All right, whatever. I got it. We're good to go. Oh, oh well shit
We're not good to go
Maybe we should take out a loan. How do we do that alone? I
Like it. Okay, take got it clown clinic required. Well, you know what god damn it
Okay, send them home. We don't have a clown Lynn go away or whatever these guys have motivation
Right good clown clinic unlock. Well, I just sent somebody home, but that's okay. Oh, no good
They're gonna send clowns after me aren't they? Well, god, damn it. Okay
Well, what we're gonna do we're gonna do is again, we're gonna get rid of this. We'll sell it
I'll make a clown clinic cuz that's how we roll clown clinic for by forth and OH
I just sold. I just sold my general Diagnostics
Why do you have to be a dick?
Why do you gotta why do you have to be a goddamn dick? Why do you got to do that to me?
Any for I wouldn't make the breakroom so goddamn big it's our playground. I can bulldoze
40 K 30 Cades this house and no playgrounds. All right, we're buying this one. We're gonna take another loan
Loan me up baby loan
Loan me but build the Clown Wing Wah, boom. All right, there's gonna be a star to the clown wing
This is we're going to build slowly. I'm not gonna build all symmetrical style Oh
What is ridiculousness
What kind of game if I walked into? What is this?
Why it's just for goddamn dick ulis now, isn't it?
That is regard to him dick ulis kind of like it though was ridiculous. But yeah, that's all right. There we go
All right, go for it. Yeah, I see we needed a new nurse
We're making a profit. So that's good even with our loans
Dagum. I've got a gum problem
All right. So what am I do I think I need to hire two assistants because this one's getting tired
I so I'm yawning and sleeping on the job. So it's good. No III really. Do I have a gun problem?
I'll like chew one piece of gum for about a minute or less and I'll be like
Okay, all the flavors gone then. I just pop it out and chew another piece of gum and ask Bob about it
He's known it since we first were roommates back in college. I've had a serious gum problem for as long as I can
Remember I did train three staff. What the hell? Whoa
Wait, what the hell everybody zoom in on that?
What the hell is going on there with their face their face is real fucked up
I don't know what's happening there, but that's that's wrong. Okay, whatever. All right training is available. There you go
Start training everything seems to be running pretty smoothly. I still haven't seen anybody actually get used to the call the clown thing
No, I'm not eating a pretzel you couldn't deal with that. Amy is even more of a saint for listening to that 24/7
Listening to what? What did I do?
Be hilarious. Is that what I did? Oh
No, such a cry me being so
Undeniably funny all the time don't know about you, but I find the real essence stream of death someone depressing
Do you think we could go a few months, but I didn't but no one died
No one no one died. Why would anybody that?
Impress the VIP with a nice Hospital. I've got a nice hospital right here. I need a psychiatrist
Where's my psychiatrist Sammy Pound?
Sammy pound baby mayor. Tabitha wind cock is coming in
Pharmacy emergency. Okay, we've got plenty of pharmacy
You do it we've got plenty of pharmacy. We got more than enough pharmacy. Oh your hearts broken. Oh
Well, whatever you have the same gum problem
Yeah, I don't know why I can't do gum for like long-term and just I can't chew gum if it doesn't have flavor
It's super weird. I feel like this is a traffic problem right here
So I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna sell this bench. I'll pick up this one. I'm rotated and do like this
That better I'm probably better you guys need to hurry the hell up
Got a few minutes too many people waiting
Okay promote, ah
That's funny
Hey
We got a star. Okay, fine. We're gonna keep going though. Okay, did I do it? I think I impressed the mayor
Help what the fuck a nat flew up my nose
what the hell and it flew by my nose and then I sniffed real hard and went right up there. oh my god
Yeah plenty of protein. I guess I think I'm done. I'm bored. This games kind of fun kind of dumb
I think we can call there. Yeah, I think it's good enough
Hope they all die, you know, in fact in fact, you know what let's go
wow what a coincidence i was waiting  for such a long time for a long pause if you thing i did a good job on fixing some of the subtitles check out my channel James Nivison, i had a lot of fun. and mark  keep doing what you are doing we love you
And there we go
nice
And we're all good. There we go. Okay. I have fun everybody else. Okay. See you. All right. Goodbye
*Outro Music*